today I'm going to try to lick my cat
using the licky brush this is Bubbe and
I've had him for about four years this
is my cat daughter Millie my cat's name
is Terry Ann from Game of Thrones you
can hear her me I went in the back out
of the the five love languages I'd say
we're both number one physical actually
she got more affectionate recently she
likes it when I just kind of like my
face on her I think she's either gonna
think it's a toy and attack my face or
she's gonna be really into it I don't
know how he's gonna feel about the brush
she likes any type of physical affection
so I'm hoping if he likes this you know
maybe it's something that he and I can
continue to do first of all it's
disgusting that it's called licky what
do you think no it looks like a sex toy
that's kind of creepy actually
this feels inappropriate this is gonna
be my tongue on my cat just relax I'm
just gonna lick you
[Music]
no it's way too much work honestly was a
little difficult to maneuver I felt like
I was gonna drool on her at any point
she doesn't really like water so I don't
think she'd be a fan of that maybe you
did as a brush it's not bad because it's
taking out all the escape hair I just
[ __ ] love this guy he's everything
for me is my greatest source of comfort
I call him a Million Dollar Baby because
I wouldn't sell this guy for a million
bucks but I'm not gonna
licky my dad that's just where I draw
the line it really is a primal thing
they enjoy it a relationship could
really grow cats think they're human
captors are large cats my god if that
was true that's my greatest dream